we're gonna talk about some freaky stuff
are we yeah we're going to talk about
shining light through walls shining
light through walls yeah so there's a
new type of particle that you can
introduce to the standard model and you
introduce it because it solves some
problems that exist in the interactions
that make protons and neutrons so that
the strong interactions so they're
called accion's what was that mean I'll
say
accion was originally the name of a
brand of washing powder I think and the
name was given to the particle because
they clean up a mess that exists in in
the strong interaction what's this mess
in the first place what needs cleaning
up there's a symmetry in the sector that
shouldn't exist so asymmetry between
particles and antiparticles that there
actually we don't expect from the theory
what that means is that there's one
parameter one number that tells you how
whether they're similar if that number
is zero their symmetry exists if the
numbers non zero then the symmetry
doesn't make this and what you'd expect
this for that number to be large and for
the symmetry to be completely broken but
what we see when we do measurements is
in fact that their symmetries there so
there's a number that you have to tune
to be really really small and that's
that's kind of uncomfortable from from
building theories we don't like having
to make numbers really really small if
you had a particle and you flip its
charge and you you do a reflection in
space if the symmetry exists it tells
you that you should get back to the same
thing so flip the charge invert
everything to me reflects them
everything physics should look the same
that's in fact what we see but the
theory predicts that we shouldn't see
that that there should be some
differences when you when you do this
interchanging theory isn't quite
matching what happens in reality right
and you just did invent a particle paper
over the cracks yeah that seems that's
basically what we do in in physics that
doesn't seem right to me that seems a
naughty that see that doesn't seem
elegant ah so so the idea the hope is
actually that it's a more elegant
solution so instead of having to have
this one number being really really
small what this new particle so this new
particle replaces that number that you
have to make really small and instead of
just deciding that it's small and that's
the end of the story you have a way of
explaining how it evolved to be small
just about anything they can do accion
can undo this particle is postulated yes
I was a problem for you
what what would we know about it would I
have a mass would I have a charge would
is it like a bit like like what what if
this particle exists mm-hmm tell me
about it
yeah it exists it has a mass that you
don't know it has interactions with all
of the other fields in the standard
model and in fact that's what makes it
really interesting because these
interactions give rise to some cool
things that we can then go and try and
see if this particle exists currently
find it like we not just now go and test
for it and break things apart and like
people looking for it yeah absolutely
and in fact that's what this light
shining through walls stuff is it's a
way of trying to look for these new
particles because they interact with
photons so what can happen is as a
photon travels through a magnetic field
it can turn into an axiom so the idea of
the experiment that people are doing
there's one at a lab in Hamburg in
Germany at the moment that they're
building the idea is you have a big
magnet and you shine a laser beam
through there through the core of the
magnet and you put a wall in the middle
so laser on one ends camera on the other
wall in the middle so you shouldn't be
seeing any light in the camera but if
these axons exist as the photons from
the laser beam travel through the
magnetic field they can turn into
accion's
and the accion's don't care about the
wall they very happily travel through
the wall and then if you're lucky the
reverse process happens on the other
side you're accion turns back into a
photon and that's what you see in your
camera the other side what you need is a
really strong really long magnet and
then you can try and find coin accion's
the nice thing about this experiment is
there's there's no background you if if
accion's don't exist you expect to see
nothing so if you see something that
tells you an axiom is that soon as you
see something you know there's an
accident you've got a limited number of
photons in your laser beam you know the
more photons you can put into your
magnet that the higher the chance that
one of them turns into an axiom so
that's the kind of engineering challenge
of doing this getting as many photons
inside your magnetic field as you can
turning up the magnetic field strength
gasps commodity you just couldn't shine
the laser for four years and just wait
for one to happen right and that's what
people people are trying to do in fact
it's just it's just a case of getting
the money building the kit and and then
leaving it to run basically has this
been built is this running or not so
that the the so it's called the Alps
experiment so the any like particle
search or accion like particles set at a
first iteration of it ran a couple of
years ago for particle physics a cheap
thing to do because they've been able to
spend essentially cannibalize some old
magnets that used to be part of a
particle collider and use those turn
those into into an acción set so they
did this kind of as a proof of concept a
couple of years ago and now they're
building 100 meter long detector to try
and search for a sealants that should be
coming that should be turning on in a
couple of years because you know so
little about accion's you don't know how
like it is that the photons going to
turn into accion so it could have been
very likely and if we'd have been lucky
the experiment that already ran would
have seen it we weren't that lucky so
it's a lot rarer than that so you have
to sort of just keep running your
experiment with more sensitivity